hey everybody welcome back to fantasy
valley this is the 10th video in the
series and it's also the second-to-last
video of the Asian part which means that
it's kind of the calm before the storm
before we get into the backstage area
and making everything of this area come
together in the next part and the big
magnum opus which is gonna be the
station and there isn't really too much
that we're really gonna be adding in
this episode so it's a bit more relaxing
and more of a laid-back recording here
just doing a bunch of stuff to finish
off the plaza which was still pretty
empty at this point and adding any kinds
of detail that I deemed necessary until
we could move on in to finishing this
part so what we're going for for
starters is making a building on the
corner here now I wanted to get a
building over here for a couple of
reasons
first I really just wanted to keep a row
of facades around the lake so there will
be some kind of ways to keep the facades
of pretty high between this building and
the very European Main streets and that
will also be the gates towards Southeast
Asia at some point in the future so that
we have one nice row of buildings which
all kind of hopefully blend very
smoothly into each other and into the
different kinds of areas that we have
but at the same time this building is
also kind of necessary because it gives
the plaza on the other side also an idea
of actually being in plaza that's kind
of enclosed by this Asian town around it
especially since the plaza with the
whirly rig on top of it is raised a
little bit and it has that little hill
on this side here I was very afraid that
the plaza would end up looking too open
and like it's less of a plaza in a cozy
little Asian area and more of like
wide-open area where I didn't really
know what to do with it so I really
wanted to make sure that around every
part of that plaza are not just a
mountain itself I had some high stuff to
look around and kind of feel as if
you're in this Asian village so this
building is really here to kind of set
the mood for both sides from which you
can look at it and it's gonna look
completely different from both sides as
well especially since you
look at the building from the other side
from a higher airplane so it's gonna be
looking quite a bit shorter from the
other side so I had to make sure that it
actually looks decent as a tall
two-story building but on the other side
it's gonna be a one-story building and
it's gonna be quite a bit lower but
that's all gonna work out hopefully fine
in the end
it's mostly inspired I took a bunch of
like different reference ideas for
things that I wanted to realistically
get in but it's mostly really inspired
by the U garden in Shanghai which has
the same kind of color palettes the
building shape and everything is really
made for this specific place here but it
actually brought me a couple of ideas
now one of those was that I wanted to
play around with the windows a bit more
many of the windows in the Asian area so
far even though I did a lot of
experimenting to get different kinds of
windows in because they're such an
important part and such a unique part as
well of this kind of building but many
of them are still somewhat the same and
I never really took a big risk and
started putting random stuff together
and hopefully finding some things that
randomly looked good and that's why I
really wanted to try here and I ended up
sinking these medieval windows or the
Coffee windows into a blank background
which kinda gives you a pretty nice
pattern it's definitely not the exact
kind of Chinese pattern that you would
maybe like to see in a case like this
but it definitely gives the same sort of
vibe and same texture especially if you
look from a distance and I'm actually
really happy with how these things turn
out it's pretty good just for the
variation to have some different kinds
of ways to play around with this stuff
when it was just fun as well to play
around with ways of creating patterns on
these walls I again just wanted to be a
bit careful with this as well since the
Asian area is definitely sucking up a
lot of Poly's which is not that great
and I can already feel my framerate
sinking quite a bit and I get a few
comments about this every now and then I
do have an i-5 and a GTX 970 which
should be able to at least take it
somewhat decent but my fps has already
dropped like three times since I started
recording this series probably even more
and it's down to about 20 at this
the only thing which I can really bank
on at this point is that FPS right now
it really seems to be based on whatever
is actually in your field of view
whereas before in alpha one for example
the FPS would stay the same no matter
what you're really looking at but I'm
not 100% sure about this but it it
definitely seems like the game is really
only rendering what you see at this
point which is good because I can
actually get the FPS up to 50 again if I
just look away from the Asian area so
the other areas will definitely be
manageable but for this part here I
still wanted to not go too crazy with
everything and completely ruin the
project that way and a couple funny
final finishing touches that I wanted to
add to the building well not really
finishing but a few other things I
wanted to play with other doors since
there aren't really any Asian doors in
the game either and I kept the doors
pretty simple so far more or less just
the sliding kind of things that already
fit into the frameworks that I had
before but making a round door with a
kind of half arch on top of it was a fun
idea that I've seen well you see on many
Asian buildings and one that I didn't
really try before so I quickly wanted to
do it there and that pretty much
concludes it for the front of the
building the back of the building is a
little bit more simple but it's also a
bit more complex in the way that it's
set up it has this separate building
which is slightly rotated to fit right
along the cue of the whirly rig here
which makes everything the entire
composition a few of the building a bit
more interesting from this side since it
is such a very low building and I still
wanted to play around with like
different roofs and different details on
its having that extra roof that sticks
out from like a little bit of a diagonal
angle seems to make it a bit more
interesting and also make sure that the
queue is covered up for a little bit and
back to the front side I still have to
finish the lower floor of the building
which I ended up making in a very simple
way and much more similar to the things
that I've only made at this point I kind
of just wanted to get it over with to be
very honest I might be putting some kind
of stuff in this building since as of
now the building doesn't really have any
kind of function beside looking
but I might also put like an information
kind of thing in this building if
there's really any kind of facility that
I still need in the Asian area that I
don't have when it's finished I can
always just remove one of these walls
and put a facility in there it's just
that for now this was the best looking
thing I figured and gave the best idea
of what this building would eventually
start looking like it also fits in to
give it some different kinds of textures
since the the second floor or the first
floor actually in the second floor all
have this white stucco pattern with
framework I definitely wanted to get
some different textures into the base
floor that's why I wanted to use a lot
more wood and stone for that floor now
here's where it's gonna get interesting
because I had been procrastinating on
this for such a long time but I really
really wanted to try it with this
building because it seemed like the
perfect fits it was really what I had in
mind for this building to work with all
along and I kept pushing it away but it
was really finally time to do it it's
actually making a roof with eight sides
the reason that I was hesitating to - so
it's just because it's pretty hard to do
it and it takes a lot of pieces like you
have to figure out exactly where you're
gonna place everything and it's also
quite tough because you don't really
have a great idea of what the roof is
gonna look like until it's completely
finished and there's no going back after
that so I wasn't entirely sure how this
was gonna work out while I was building
it but these oxycodone roofs are just
something that you see on many of these
Chinese buildings and it's something
that I really wanted to feature in here
I didn't have it at all in the Asian
area and I felt super bad about it so
yeah I want to give a shot and probably
torture myself with the making of it in
the meantime so the way that I really
wanted to do it here is lay out the
basic framework first so I have a bit of
a reference of how everything is gonna
work out the diagonal beam had to be
made separately from the regular one
side to constantly check whether they
were actually the same length I'm going
down to the same heights which they seem
to be so that was okay and then I had to
fill in the middle pieces with the
wooden planks actually give it that sort
of roof
texts to turrets which is this is where
all the ponies are rats and this is
where it's gonna like my came a little
bit that was the middle part and then
finally for the very last part of the
roof I had to make sure that actually
looks like a tiled roof from the side as
well so I ended up putting the pillars
on the side here matching up with the
placement of the planks to make it look
as if there is actually a fancy Chinese
tiled roof and that is the very basic
roof but it doesn't really have too much
of a shape on its own so I wanted to
finish it off with some very basic
details around the edges and the top of
the roof so I placed some planks on the
side I put that very small golden kind
of curl on the side because these go
these golden ornaments are something
that you actually see on many of these
kinds of roofs and I figured it would
fit in quite nicely here a couple of
railings just to make the frames a bit
more interesting and I also quickly
wanted to fill in the rest of the roofs
with very similar ornaments just to make
sure that the entire style of the
building is consistent throughout all of
the different roofs and the last thing
that I wanted to do here I'm not
entirely sure if I remember oh yeah
first actually had to finish a little
like plateau underneath the roof to
actually have something which the roof
can stand on and give a small pavilion
on top of the building which was a bit
of a struggle for a while because it
turned out to be a little bit defensive
when I first built it but then it turned
out that just placing the railing inside
a little bit more make the entire
appearance of the top of the roof a
little bit less Phat's bit more elegance
and I'm quite happy with how that turned
out and the very final elements of the
roof is the top part where I didn't want
to go too crazy but I at least wanted to
add some fancy bits to it and ended up
stacking whatever kind of scenery
elements was really working out here and
putting a bunch of ridiculous stuff
together and so it looked good pretty
much and in the end I'm pretty happy
with how the different roof elements and
different planks and wooden brackets all
work together to make this fancy spire
which is funny because one of the
reasons that I do feel that this entire
build is at least a little bit more
fantasy than just complete completely
being Chinese or Japanese is in a very
subtle thing but something which you
don't really see in Asian architecture
cultures that much is that a lot of the
the focus on building shapes in these
kinds of Asian architecture is very
horizontal you have the wide roofs you
have like the very wide square buildings
with a lot of the details on the roofs
and on the walls but you don't actually
have any very tall spires or towers
clock towers and her large castle gates
as you would have a European
architecture which is super vertical
especially if you have like gothic kind
of architecture and what I still really
wanted to try here is as much as I could
add all of these ridiculous over-the-top
vertical elements that you probably
wouldn't see in most real Asian
buildings and one of those examples
would really be the spire on top of the
pavilion which is quite a bit larger
than a real Asian counterpart would
usually make it but it's those kinds of
details are really mostly in some of the
other buildings which I met like the
towers or the building which is right
next to the Japanese gates which has
like a couple of vertical spires which
don't actually make that much
architectural sense it's brilliant that
kind of stuff then I at least wanted to
make it a bit less realistic and try and
play around with things to make it a bit
more attractive for a theme park anyway
moving on because I am super lagging
behind one way in which I wanted to fill
in the side of this plaza to enclose it
a bit more make it a bit more like it's
a cute cozy little town Plaza is to add
a roll on this side the reason I wanted
to add a war instead of buildings is
well for one because it's very
time-saving I didn't want to go and make
lot of buildings over here kind of want
to move on at this point but also it
helps actually keep this space behind it
quite open there's not a lot of space
left here for the Southeast Asian area
and I definitely want to keep as much
open as I can so I got this sort of
Japanese sand garden
inspired war that you will mostly see
around many
or a samurai homes that kind of stuff
with a bunch of decorations some windows
and things that you wouldn't really see
in a war like this but are still pretty
nice to look at from this side so I
figured why not add them and that pretty
much finishes that side but there's one
last building that I wanted to build
right here and it's not really a
building per se it's just a bit of a
small pavilion and it's a small entrance
into the cue of the whirly rig which is
kind of stupid because it is just a
whirly rig
I mean who gives a [ __ ] about a twirly
really it's just a kiddie ride and
perhaps I shouldn't put so much effort
into theming at any rate but I wanted to
add a building over here just because it
is a good way to get another building in
with some kind of purpose not just being
the entrance of a queue which makes the
entire area a bit more interesting than
if I would just have a ball run around
it the entire time and it's also a nice
opportunity to play around with some
different things again because what I
also didn't do yet is trying to make a
round more European kind of little tower
roof which is something that you rarely
see but I have seen it on a couple of
occasions and I figured it might
actually fit in here and it's it can
always be a fun thing to play around
with and if it works we can keep it and
that's pretty much the idea that I went
into this little pond in with so um yeah
I decided to play run with that forbids
it's gonna be pretty simple just one
quarter of a very simple really
kind of castle like roof here with the
details that should really hopefully
make it location in the end and the
reason that I wanted to put all of these
weird scenery stuff underneath it and
why I eventually ended up stuffing a
burger underneath the roof is because I
wanted to support it with some kind of
more Asian like way to support it as
opposed to just having a couple of
wooden beams to hold it up so that's
what we're going for here and finally I
had to insert a couple of different wall
sections to actually make sure that the
entire thing is one big solid piece that
you can stake right on top of that roof
and actually have it all just be sound
and looking good hopefully
and there's also another way in which I
think the tower can actually be quite
handy you might be looking at it at this
point and figuring why the hell that you
do that that looks pretty damn weird I
want to get some kind of high vertical
marker on this building just because
everything else around this area is
gonna be pretty low the wall is pretty
low it's gonna be a bit of foliage
behind it there's no real like building
elements that you can see from far away
and that's where the tower and in a
little bit as well the roof behind
underneath it comes in you can actually
still see the tower pick up if you're
looking at this part of the park from
say for instance the bridge down at the
tea house or if you're walking into this
area if you come over the pass
underneath the flying coaster which
doesn't make too much of a difference it
definitely isn't some kind of big greeny
that you see in the distance and are
like wow that's amazing I'm gonna go
there but it is at least something that
provides a bit of a backdrop it's a bit
taller and it Peaks out a bit and gives
you the idea that there are actually
buildings and that there's actually a
town plaza in the distance if you look
at this place from a bit further away
instead of just being one big foliage
for which it would otherwise look like
so it just kind of brings in the Asian
town setting a bit more if you look at
this area from a different kind of
perspective so in that sense I guess
it's also a bit of a mini really if that
makes any sense it probably doesn't I'm
probably gonna have to explain that term
every now and then if you're a new
viewer by the way a weenie is basically
a building that is designed to kind of
attract people into a certain area that
you look at from a distance say the
disney castle or the disney space
mountain building that kind of stuff is
basically what a weenie is all about and
this building is way too small to
actually be a weenie but though i wanted
to have it for a similar kind of
function and the rest of the detailing
kind of reflects that as well at this
point i didn't really give too much of a
[ __ ] anymore and i just wanted to finish
it in a way that would fit in with the
rest of the area try to mix a bunch of
different elements which I didn't really
mix before like the very small pillar
elements on top of the pillar
underneath the roof which can fit in
quite well and I figured hey might
actually use that in the station in the
future as well and a bunch of different
planters and small objects to make
everything look a bit more charming but
that's really just about it
no rocket science going on there now
when the rocket science is gonna happen
though is gonna be in the next episode
or it's not exactly gonna be rocket
science but I am looking forward to it
it's one of my favorite episodes and
I'll be building this station and
off-screen doing the backstage areas and
basically making the entire area
finished so hope you guys enjoyed this
episode and I'll see you guys next time